[Musique]
depuis des années elle avait tendance à
se faire moins remarquée la voici qui
revient en 2020 la cigarette à attirer
de plus en plus de français
d'après les derniers chiffres de santé
publique france +2 3 adultes sur dix se
déclarent fumeurs occasionnels 1,4 point
de plus qu'en 2010 neuf mois on a deux
revenus lui aux fumées regarder plus
d'un quart des français 25 % fut plus de
25% fument tous les jours contre 24% en
2019 santé publique france qui parle là
une stabilisation
72% des anciens fumeurs comme vous
affirme que voir quelqu'un fumée dans un
film ça leur donne envie de fumer et
puis à propos des jeunes 37 % des
adolescents disent s'être mis à fumer
après avoir vu des acteurs souvent dans
les films
je dois être la seule en france à avoir
arrêté de fumer une semaine avant le co
financé environ c'est le 7 mars 2010 pas
mal pour une fois ta vie ou énorme et
l'a arrêté le 16 à 2020 et donc la
attendait non mais j'ai mon compteur
maintenant deux mois 18 jours vous savez
combien j'ai gagné j'ai gagné j'ai
économisé 4447 euros mais tu vas payer à
voir je vais mettre un baume je serais
pour qui un bon ben moubamba marquisat
pour moi en hockey est pompée est très
bien fait plaisir tu vois ouais et après
j'espère que ça va faire quoi je mets
bien et où alors ce soir je me mets sur
mon 30 2 mais bon quand je mets des
crottes sur le corps volontairement
c'est bizarre
bah j'aime bien c'est mon préféré en
plus la dernière fois j'ai vu des
crottes sur un put jamais été mon petit
enzo qui vient de naître mais ça c'est
des mots n'étaient pas si mon salon
c'est au salon
e
alors que je comprenne bien c'est un
salon
en même temps c'est un dressing salle de
sport une salle de jeux et puis un peu
aussi une poubelle
c'est bagdad c'est un peu la maison
ah oui ici c'est la maison quand on se
voit pas ici en soit sur le plateau on a
le chic et sur la scène de l'opéra
comique pour le manque de foi c'est un
tonique pour la liste je me suis dit
c'est tous les deux on est un peu les
billons c'est de jezzine président
européen
est ce que vous êtes d'accord c'est ce
que tu as raison moi je suis d'accord
bon ben vous allez être obligé regarder
on a fait un petit mouton ça c'est grand
est ce que tu te rappelles de ce qu'il
ya là dedans
non non pas ce que tu veux voir oui
stone mais alors là tu commences à avoir
une culture de champignons de poids les
deux à temps aux m'attendais pas à ça
car allah tabusse jeanne de
retentissants parole parce qu'en général
c'est là qu'ils se vautre mais d'une
famille est rare et a donc continué
amusé à toi lise au toit s'il s'agit
bien là au bal chez n'aurions léger et
l'adolescent blessé la politesse ou à
votre âge vous devrez savoir en laisse
parler les gens après vous ramenez votre
phase des poules non non non je peux pas
laisser dire et moi c'est mignon c'est
mon ami
si je veux lui parler je fais ce que je
suis mais alors qu'on ne doit pas faire
mieux et on verra
non non pas petit frère de gamal calmes
parce que tu ne sais pas que ce pré rond
raquette le gamin je te sautent dessus
des personnes mais t'inquiète pas une
baisse de la pression ce que talent hier
en tout cas ça reconnaît du monde
voilà ce que nous sommes
on se peut ça empêche de tomber malade
la réponse est non
il savait très bien ici parce qu il en
fait son show comme d'habitude je lui
avais appris dans les aventuriers que
quand on gagne on est humble en fait qd
mais non il a toujours pas compris la
mobilité c'est pas son truc
vous allez taiz avait 13 14 ans il ya
des y est ddd d'aider des jeunes filles
13 14 ans qui venait de lune de
stuttgart de lyon et tous qui jouer mais
ça jouer mais quand on a un grand machin
dans les buts on fait comment quand ça
veut rien dire on est très agile ce soit
il précise petite bête ça serait pas
mieux que je mange nouvelles attentes je
repasse par texto rigoles ou quoi toi
maman je me perds tu es sûr que tu veux
faire ça bloque de l'eau lourde marquée
lourd lourd blot stéphane c'est quoi
votre première pensée qui vous vient
quand on dit le mot mariage
lully fourche la balle radio c'est le
stade je pense suivant au mariage
d'accord j'attendais
[Musique]
j'attends l'amour la douceur
la chair
ben en fait je me suis connecté sur
facebook
je fais d'habitude pour pouvoir garder
les cages et où ils facebook oui excusez
moi je suis un peu bouché mais je pense
que tout le monde sur le plateau a
compris sur sex boucle je me suis dit ya
le décès prend une toute autre tournure
qu'avait ce qu'elle est il donna le
premier roi de france louis xiv
non jean françois 1er françois 1er ce
n'est pas le premier président
mais non c'était un roi non lui je vous
rejoins la présidence à peu françois
konan ans françois mitterrand c'est
jacques mitterrand l'image de ce bébé
girafe ce girafes ont subjugué par sa
propre ombre au zoo de mon art hausse et
en australie on regardera la regarder il
a toujours nombreux j'ai pas que ça me
rappelle ici aussi j'ai été surpris par
mon ombre l'autre jour parce qu'il y
avait du soleil c'est pour ça c'est sûr
c'est trop mignon
on est séché pour le confort et la bien
venue bien cette piste images toujours
de phoenix en arizona pas moins de 21
bébés furets sont nés j'aurais pu vous
posez la question tiens je sais que
petit alors ce ne sont pas des petits
rats blancs se dit s'écrit à l'écran ce
sont des petits dés petit furet à pattes
noires l'une des espèces les plus
menacées en amérique du nord qu'elle
était considérée comme éteinte il ya
quelques années pourrait viser
visiblement ça ça repart ainsi gérard
vers nous en parler bon voyage et babeth
télématin va commencer